daniel leray bonsoir soit très content
de vous retrouver et très content de
votre premier choix milan kundera le
dernier qui est déroutante absolument je
vous dirais qu'ils cultivent l'art du
paradoxe comme jamais dans ce roman
milan kundera c'est un livre qui nous
arrive comme un cadeau cette fête de
l'insignifiance milan kundera 85 ans
quand même il n'avait pas publié deux
romans depuis onze ans c'est un de nos
grands écrivains des grands écrivains de
notre époque donc tchèque d'origine qui
vit en france depuis 1975 traduit dans
une trentaine de langues on pense bien
sûr souvent quand on pense à lui à
l'insoutenable légère d'une période dont
nul on a tous eu le chat devrait
qui a été adapté d'ailleurs au cinéma
avec juliette binoche
là on est dans un lit beaucoup plus
court plus brefs plus dépouillée mais
encore une fois beaucoup d'ironie
beaucoup de légèreté ce qui domine
surtout c'est la bonne humeur dans ce
livre là on suit un groupe d'amis tous
des hommes qui ont chacun leurs
occupations chacun leur vie et à mon ami
se rencontrent tous dans une fête mais
qui devient une fête de l'insignifiance
pas possible mais tout ça c'est un
prétexte pour kundera c'est un prétexte
enfants pour poser toutes sortes de
questions et pour s'amuser et pour nous
amuser il ya beaucoup de beaucoup
question de la séduction ça c'est
souvent le cas chez kundera dont bien
sommes par exemple qui on est à paris
qui regardent les jeunes filles qui
s'aperçoit qu'ils ont tout le nom brille
dénudé et qu'ils y mais qu'est ce que
c'est que cette mode autrefois les
femmes séduisait par leurs seins et
leurs fesses leurs cuisses pourquoi
cette obsession du nombre y est donc ça
va revenir ça plus tard d'un roman un
autre hamdi non le meilleur moyen
séduire une femme c'est pas de se
montrer brillant c'est d'avoir l'air
vraiment et signifiant comme sans la
femme se sent pas obligée d'entrer en
compétition avec vous l'insignifiance la
libère elle devient insouciant et vous
pouvez la séduire je suis
beaucoup de finnair et je vous dirai à
la fin du roman on ne sait pas
finalement est ce qui fait l'éloge de
l'insignifiance ou est ce qu'il trouve
ça terrible c'est toujours comme ça qu
on dirait on sait pas trop sur quel pied
danser ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est un
livre je voudrais que la bonne humeur
est contagieuse et quand on ferme le
livre on ne veut vraiment pas envie de
se prendre au sérieux n'est vraiment pas
et voilà alors milan kundera la fête de
l'insignifiant vous livre l'album
multicolores lui louise dupré tout un
autre dit louis une grande poète
d'ailleurs d'abord poète québécoise mais
aussi romancière qui avait publié entre
autres la memoria un très beau roman qui
lui avait valu plusieurs prix là on n'y
vraiment dans le cadre du livre
autobiographique c'est un livre sur la
mort de la mère le livre commence donc
c'est vraiment louise brics met en scène
elle est au chevet de sa mère qui
viennent mourir sous ses yeux et qu'est
ce que ça fait c'est à dire qu'on plonge
ou car de l'intimé en étant coeur de
l'universel on a tous des parents on
risque tous de les perdre et encore plus
je vous dirai ce qui est plus fort celle
qui nous a donné la vie qui meurt devant
nous qu'est ce que ça fait qu'est ce que
nous dit louise du prix ça fait quand on
entrevoit donc sa propre mort à venir ce
livre grave mais aussi avec des accents
très touchant une belle tendresse jusque
on m'a dit que demain nous juridiquement
écrit très beau très fort louise dupré
l'album multicolores daniel merci
beaucoup ont même bien sûr ces titres là
sur notre page facebook tg 18h mesdames
et messieurs jean nous allons je vais
dans quelques minutes le tout et avec
les
l'un titre mais c'est toujours donc en
prison se retrouve dans deux semaines
merci merci